tutti ragazzi e benvenute questo nuovo
video io sono per i generi salutati
sulla vonn gas
raga oggi abbiamo fatto una partita da
allora ho fatto delle col dal quoziente
intellettivo che proprio l'ho inventato
io consentente alle 19 di dediche collo
fatto guardate di stovini maledizione
[Musica]
allora giochiamo a per bene comunque
hanno messo il l'aggiornamento di
halloween ci sono tutte le proprie di
halloween nella navicella fighissimo
bene stiamo attenti perché qua su tutti
un po rom pick up step e nicky stiamo ai
ammette la misera che qualcuno che ore
alle donne che noi avessimo io comunque
io stavo in med sono uscito dalla mente
dopo aver fatto cosa deprimente sono
nate in corridoio per andare verso le
alture c'era il corpo di cesca perché
per che volessero io faccio siamo persi
per forza si paga in un braccio chi ha
fatto stato chi è stato abbastanza bene
l'ha fatta velocissimo e comunque stare
attenta charlie nel dubbio magari va
allora dai ragazzi secondo me e charlie
è un fortissimo sospetto di marci
ma veramente bello pesante il sospetto
di margine io credo possa essere marci
in tutto ciò all reja
ma dovete schifo la ragnatela grossa
come una casa di security che orribile
maledetto nikiniki mini quad e vai lui e
quali per le tasche emergenza alle
storie vita altrui alla mano certo ok ma
mai successa rai su non mi fido di marci
non mi fido di charlie nessuna delle due
salita qua o hanno chiuso charlie
attenzione oddio hanno chiuso tutte le
porte tra charlie e m incredibile
non so se è stata charlie che voleva
fare la [ __ ] ma non ho idea non meno me
la conta giusta ragazzi vediamoci qua
c'è qualcuno non c'è nessuno bene però
fare la stata schiena elettrica
mi porto nichi io ho visto nichi che
stava in seguito guarda le telecamere e
l'unica persona che ho visto lì march è
stato penso 40 minuti a fare la destra e
io l'ho portato tutto il tempo quindi
stavamo tutti e due in aree c'era ecco
all'inizio a guardare i testi voi andate
via
e come percorso il call di como ecco
ecco ecco ecco abbastanza allettante fa
eco charlie stanno parlando magari erano
notate nel senso una corsa e non era
ecco abbiamo perso perché basta un'altra
kill a sto punto programma a premere il
pulsante vediamo se ci aveva azzeccato
raga vediamo se ci avevamo azzeccato
seno abbiamo perso perché basta nakheel
in quel caso charlie ma sappiamo casa
abbiamo ciccato ecco abbiamo perso
perché sentirsi vinci subito ad esempio
se io sto con una confavi c 10 su 10
charlie
da notare che mi sono rotto da sola
comunque sì
era giusto e ha detto che siamo tutto da
sola
marianna cui 2009 ma che col mamma mia
[Musica]
raga sono impostore con steve fair e
mamma mia che partita raga veramente una
partita pazzesca questo se ci pensate
porco demonio è da una vita che non mi
capitava di essere impostare costate
felice non c'entra niente ma dai chi li
amo ex band
andiamocene sono mia verità nessuno sto
provando a vedere se riesco a fare un po
di casino in giro perché l'unica roba
e non solo perché dicono la foto che
meno giocare non si estingue si giocano
si parte
non si può darsi che fa vessicchio si è
votato vestiti a festa anche gescal
eccoli la doppia ragazzi siamo la doppia
mamma mia ragazzi incredibile meno male
che sono uscito e sono usciti dovevo
parlare io che cosa allora sono
veramente in pochi in giro è quindi raga
direi di di muoversi omar ci fu step ma
stefano nè ma scusami ma stefanone
impostore non lo sono sognato la stessa
impostore con me perché non perché mi è
comparso non impostore no ho sbagliato
chiuso le porte di elettrica
oddio mi appare ci sono incastrati nelle
borse la voce dei venti la mente chi
lati insieme ragazzi 121 e vado radio
accanto al resto due l'ha fatta ha fatto
me è qualcun altro entra nuke proprio
non lo so come mai se partito a chiamare
che abituati il live sibolga volte la
tratta pure in quattro così si era un po
difficile vincere questa partita e 38
rosso
io comunque ho fatto se non a chi non mi
aspettavo pisa crisi va bene è perché
non ti ho mai incontrati grazie tematico
yo yo yo è stato così io devo fare le
nuovole giudice o facevo youtuber poi il
giudice ha detto ragazzi scheda che ha
lasciato un bel commento qua sotto che
li leggiamo nelle giamo killer io li
leggo che voi non mica leggete leggo io
e noi ci vediamo come sempre al prossimo
video da ragazzi
[Musica]
no